tout est possible j'ai traversé de
nombreuses épreuves
l'essentiel est de ne jamais renoncer
voici le message que wendy renard veut
faire passer à la jeunesse et
particulièrement à ceux de son pays et
la martinique
un pays auquel les fortement attachés et
qu'elle raconte dans son autobiographie
son enfance au prêcheur et ses
rencontres déterminantes qui vont
changer son extraordinaire destin
jocelyn germé le ctr et de nombreux
autres figures du football martiniquais
et charlène marichal kevin parsemaient
et bien d'autres mais il n'ya pas que le
monde du sport qui a influencé la jeune
wendy sa famille ses proches ses amis
qu'on était une force déterminante pour
sa réussite qu'elle nous parle de la foi
de sa mère de l'affection de ses tempes
la complicité avec sa soeur son ami sont
pareils qui jouera un rôle fondamental à
la mort de son père un père qu'elle
adorait puis ce sera le départ de la
france clairefontaine l'olympique
lyonnais et le parcours fulgurant de la
jeune pré shooting
son livre est parsemé d'expression
créole et de rappels constants à son île
ses coups de blues sa nostalgie la barre
loin des siens
des témoignages inédits de ses proches
une préface signée félix mérine est un
livre qui dispensent toutes ces valeurs
de courage de respect de combativité des
valeurs sûres pour cette jeune femme qui
a remporté tous les titres et est
considérée comme une des meilleures
joueuses du monde
[Applaudissements]